I had a conversation with Benjamin at
yahu and he said fundamentally if you're
anti-zionist you're
anti-semitic so the the the Zionist
project is tied at the hip to the Jewish
project what do you have to say to that
look you can Define
anti-Semitism any way you want right and
you can Define anti-Semitism to
incorporate anti-zionism
uh and uh I think we have reached the
point where
anti-Semitism is identified today not
just with anti-zionism but with
criticism of Israel if you criticize
Israel people will say some people will
say you're an
anti-semite and if that's your
definition of anti-semitism ISM it's
taken an important term and stretched it
to the point where it's
meaningless right so when Steve and I
wrote the book uh wrote the article and
then wrote the book all sorts of people
said that we were anti-semites this is a
ludicrous charge but what they meant was
you're criticizing the lobby you're
criticizing Israel and therefore you're
an
anti-semite
okay if that's what an anti-semite is
somebody who criticizes Israel you know
probably half the Jewish Community if
not more in the United States is
anti-Semitic and of course you get into
all these crazy games where people are
calling Jews self-hating Jews and
anti-semites because they're critical of
Israel but even people who are
anti-zionists I don't think they're
anti-semitic at all uh you can argue
they're misguided that's fine but uh
many of these people are Jewish and
proud of the fact that they're Jewish
they just don't believe that nationalism
and Jewish nationalism is a force that
should be applauded and you want to
understand that in the American context
there is a rich tradition of anti-
Zionism right and these were not people
who were anti-semites if you go back to
the 30s 40s 50s and the same thing was
even true in Europe there were all sorts
of European Jews who were opposed to
Zionism
were they anti-semites I don't think so
but we've gotten to the point now where
people are so interested in stopping any
criticism of Israel that they wield this
weapon of uh calling people anti-semites
uh so uh Loosely that uh the term has
kind of lost meaning so I I think
Netanyahu is is wrongheaded to equate uh
anti-zionism with anti-Semitism Alan dtz
was one of the people that called you
specifically anti-semitic U so
just looking at the space of
discourse how do
you where's the Slither of Hope for
healthy discourse about us relationships
with
Israel
um between you and alen dtz and others
like him well I think until there is a
settlement of the Israeli Palestinian
conflict there's no hope of putting an
end to this nonsense right so these are
just uses of terms to kind
of cheat your way through the through
the discourse it's shortcut no it's the
silence people right it's very very
important to understand that one of the
Lobby's principal goals is to make sure
we don't have an open discourse a free
willing discourse about Israel
because they understand people in the
lobby understand that if you have an
open discourse Israel will end up
looking very bad right you don't want to
talk about the occupation you don't want
to talk about how Israel was created
right all all these subjects are ones
that uh will cause problems for Israel
see just to go to the present crisis
okay when you have a disaster
and what happened on October 7th is a
disaster one of the first things that
happens is that people begin to ask the
question how did this happen right
what's the root cause of this problem
this is a disaster we have to understand
what caused it so that we can work to uh
to make sure it doesn't happen again so
we can work to shut it down and then
make sure it doesn't happen again but
once you start talking about the root
causes right you end up talking about
how Israel was created right and that
means telling a story that is not pretty
about how the zionists conquered
Palestine uh and number two it means
talking about the occupation right it's
not like uh Hamas attacked on October
7th because there were just a bunch of
anti-semites who hated Jews
and wanted to kill Jews this is not you
know Nazi Germany right this is directly
related to the occupation and to what
was going on inside of Gaza and it's not
in Israel's interest or the Lobby's
interest to have an open discourse about
what the Israelis have been doing to the
Palestinians since I would say roughly
1903 when the second alah came to Israel
or came to what was then Palestine right
want to talk about that and we don't
want to talk about from the Lobby's
point of view the influence that the
lobby has right uh it's better from the
Lobby's point of view if most Americans
think that uh American support of Israel
is just done for all the right moral and
strategic reasons not because of the
lobby and when John mirer and Steve Walt
come along and say you have to
understand that this special
relationship is due in large part to the
Lobby's influence that is not an
argument that uh people in the lobby
want to hear so the point is you have to
go to Great Lengths for all these
reasons you have to go to Great Lengths
to silence people like me and Steve Walt
and one of the ways to do that is to
call us anti-semites I think the chapter
or the section of the book where we talk
about this charge of anti-Semitism is
called the Great silencer that's what we
call the charge of anti-Semitism the
great silencer who wants to be called an
anti-semite especially in the wake of
the Holocaust do I want to be called an
anti-semite oh my God no uh and uh so
it's very effective but you know it is
important to talk about these issues in
my humble opinion and I think if we had
talked about these issues uh way back
when it would have gone a long way
towards uh you know maybe getting a
two-state solution which I think was the
best alternative here it it's
complicated and I I wonder if you can
comment on the complexity of this
because criticizing Israel and you know
criticizing the
lobby can
um for a lot of people be a dog whistle
for sort of anti-Semitic conspiracy
theories that you know this idea that
Jews run everything run the world or
this kind of
cabal and you know
it's it's also very true that people who
are legitimately
anti-semitic are also critics of Israel
in the same kind of way and so it's such
a complicated landscape in which to have
discussions because
um uh you know even people like David
Duke uh who are you know racist don't
racist on the
surface I haven't listened to him enough
but like you know there's dog whistles
it's it's a complicated space in which
to have
discussions because it um I mean I
wonder if you can sort of speak to
that um because there's this silencing
effect of calling everybody anti-semitic
but it's also true that there is
anti-Semitism in the world like there is
the size of population people that hate
Jews there's probably a sizeable
population of people who hate Muslims
too but you know I a lot of hate out
there a lot of hate out there uh but the
hatred of Jews has like a long history
and so you have like you know Rolling
Stones have a a set of great hits and
there's just a set of great hits of the
ways conspiracy theories that you can
make up about the Jews that are used as
part of the hatred uh so there's like
nice templates for that and I I just
wonder if if you can comment
on operating as a historian as an
analyst as a strategic thinker in this
kind of space yeah we obviously when we
wrote the article which we did before
the book gave the subject a great deal
of thought I mean uh what you say just
now is music to our ears I'm talking for
me and about me and Steve uh I mean I
think that you know your point about dog
whistles is
correct look we went to Great Lengths to
make it clear that this is not a cabal
it's not a conspiracy and in fact in a
very important way the lobby operates
out in the open right
uh they brag about their power right and
this was true before we wrote the
article right and um and we said in the
article and the book and you heard me
say it here first of all it's not a
Jewish Lobby
right um secondly it's not a cabal right
it's an American interest group and and
the American system is designed such
that interest groups are perfectly legal
and some of them are super effective
exact I mean you hit the nail right on
the head that's exactly right
and you know and there was nothing that
we said that was
anti-semitic by any reasonable
definition of that term and you know
huge numbers of Jews have known me and
Steve over the years and nobody ever
ever said that we were
anti-semitic before March 2006 when the
article appeared because we're not
anti-semitic but look you've got this
interest group right that has a
significant influence on American
policy and on Israeli
policy
and you want to talk about it it's just
important to talk about it it's
important for Jews right in the United
States for Jews in Israel to talk about
this the idea that you want to silence
critics is not a smart way to go about
doing business in my
opinion if we were wrong if Steve and I
were so wrong and arguments were so foul
they could have easily exposed those
arguments they could have gone uh into
combat with this in terms of the
marketplace of ideas and easily knocked
this down the problem was that our
arguments were quite powerful and
instead of engaging us and defeating our
arguments they wanted to silence us and
this is not good right it's not good for
Israel it's not good for the United
States and I would argue in the end if
anything it's going to Foster
anti-Semitism I think you don't want to
run around telling people that they
can't talk about Israel without being
called an anti-semite it's just not it's
not healthy uh in terms of the issue
that you're raising right but I still
agree with you that it is a tricky issue
it's I I don't want to make light of
that you know I know that there's 's
this piece of literature out there
called the protocols of the Elders of
Zion and I fully understand that if
you're not careful you can come close to
writing volume two of the protocol but I
don't believe that we wrote anything
that was even close to that and again I
think that a healthy debate on the
issues that we were raising would have
been in not only in America's interest
but it would have been in Israel's
interest